well let's have a look now at the
strategic situation on the ground in
ukraine i'm joined by air marshal edward
stringer good afternoon ed thanks for
being here um so just explain to us what
exactly is going on in the south
does ukraine have the strategic ability
to do what they're hoping to do
well zelinski's been quite clear that
he's not going to talk about the
tactical aims of this military operation
but they have been at the strategic
level signaling now for weeks that they
are going to
take the initiative with and move on to
the offensive in the southern region of
ukraine
so what we're seeing now in this area
you can see to the north and west of the
dunipa river which the russians had
taken we can see the ukrainian forces
exerting a very comprehensive push
across the whole territory
we've seen them accelerate their use of
precision missiles and artillery on the
remaining one or two significant lines
of communication to further choke off
any reinforcements or resupply to that
force and that is to make
the russian holding of that land pretty
untenable and clearly one way or another
the ukrainians are now hoping to force
the russians back across the dunepa
river because they no longer have the
combat power to hold that territory
and the south is a strategically
important area
anyway
how important do you think it is that
ukraine takes the initiative now this
moment particularly before winter
approaches
yes that's a very that's a very good
question uh it's strategically important
because of those main ports
strategically important to ukraine but
also strategically important to russia
because crimea has its only warm water
port for the black sea fleet in
sevastopol and also has some very major
airfields military bases and
and logistic
hubs
but what zolensky is trying to do is to
make sure that he can demonstrate he can
seize the initiative and he's not just
reacting to
a war that's being dictated by russia he
wants to show that he can go on on the
offensive and therefore demonstrate
principally to the west
that ukraine is capable of prevailing
over russia and therefore
allow western political leaders to
continue to support him when times get
tight with the economic crisis with the
price of gas throughout the autumn into
winter and maybe into next year
also if they do succeed in pushing the
russian forces
out of the west bank then actually
ukrainian forces are now very much
closer and within range of crimea which
is going to pose a serious strategic
military problem for russia so in both
the military and political spheres this
would mean a major success for zielinski
would allow him to retain that political
support
and as we've been talking a lot about mr
gorbachev today following his passing
one of president putin's aims has been
to rebuild the soviet union that mr
gorbachev lost
do you think there's any chance he'll
succeed
well putin is no gorbachev
and actually gorbachev genuinely
believed in the union of soviet
socialist republics and perestroika and
glasnost attempts to try and get it to
work properly in a way perhaps that the
chinese arguably have uh have been able
to do
but of course that led to the breakup of
that soviet union and to his great
credit gorbachev did not use violence or
force to keep the union together even
though the hard line has pressed him to
do so
putin is one of those hardliners he has
shown he is very willing to use force to
subjugate territories and i don't think
he's trying to rebuild the soviet union
he is much more cyrus he's trying to
rebuild the russian empire with a series
of scared nations having to do his
bidding as he's only managed to take
less than 20 of ukraine at the moment
after six months i don't think he has
much power left to do anything else and
therefore yes i think he is set to fail
in that ambition
hey marshall ed stringer thanks very
much for that
thank you